do start with breaking news a large fire
at a strip mall near jones and vegas
drive in the near northwest valley a
two-alarm fire that's right we've got
hector mejia joining us live there on
the scene hector earlier we saw them
attacking the fire from the air how does
it look
well
now
have made significant progress but let
me show you here we're standing on the
lanes of jones here you can see some
flames still shooting here from this
building they have made progress but you
can see those flames are still burning
we do have some good news here that is
no injuries to report the bad news as
you can see this fire has been burning
for more than an hour
likely a devastating devastating loss
here for
the market apollo market as well as the
mexican restaurant right next door
filipinos what we know about the fire so
far is that fire crews got the call just
after five o'clock this morning you can
see the response right now the entire
intersection is shut down as many as 60
firefighters are still out here besides
battling the flames they're also having
to deal with some pretty cold
temperatures feels like probably one of
the coldest mornings of the season so
far but you can see live those flames
still shooting from the top of the roof
there at apollo market right here at the
intersection of vegas drive and jones
we're standing by for more details as
they work to reopen this intersection
for the morning traffic but as you can
see in the meantime the intersection
remains shut down for the fire which is
still burning reporting live hector
mejia live local now